good morning Hank it's Tuesday so this
is the Pantheon the world's oldest
building still in use depending on your
definition of building and use it was
finished around 1:26 EE during the reign
of the Roman Emperor Hadrian seen here
noseless in his most famous statue which
by the way was recently discovered to be
a forgery Hadrian's head was put on
someone else's body 1,700 years after
his death
right so the Pantheon was originally a
temple to the Roman gods but it became a
Christian Church in 609 and it still is
one for almost 1,900 years people have
been coming to this place to worship so
long that the gods have changed when the
pantheon was built there was no English
language Romans didn't eat pizza because
tomatoes wouldn't come to Italy for
another 1,500 years if you wanted to get
from Rome to Florence and you were
phenomenally wealthy it would take four
days by carriage at a cost of 350
denarii I approximately equal to a
year's wages for a laborer today it
takes about three hours by car or three
and a half if you want to avoid the
tolls in short human life was very
different nineteen hundred years ago and
yet this is the Lascaux cave in
southwestern France which was discovered
or rediscovered in 1940 by four
teenagers and a dog named robot the cave
is famous for its nearly 2,000
prehistoric wall paintings including
extraordinary depictions of animals some
of them now extinct as well as this
famous person with a bird head now
there's a lot we don't know about these
paintings at Lesko we don't know for
instance how many generations painted
there but we do know from carbon dating
and other dating methods that the
paintings are mostly between 15 and
20,000 years old 350 kilometres away a
group of cave experts found another cave
full of extraordinary paintings in 1996
this one came to be known as the Chauvet
Cave and in many ways these paintings
are even more sophisticated than the
ones from Lascaux there's more action in
them like animals locking horns or drawn
so as to intimate motion and the Chauvet
paintings are also arguably more
detailed but the Chauvet paintings are
much older than the Lapps Gogh paintings
like much much older
most of these paintings were made
between 37 and 33 thousand years ago
although a few were created during a
second period of activity 31 to 28
thousand years ago that means the
historical distance between Chauvet and
Lascaux is approximately equal to the
historical distance
between Lesko and now and even more
remarkably the paintings in the Chauvet
Cave were created across thousands of
years meaning that that cave was almost
certainly in use by the same community
for longer than the Pantheon has been in
use by us we like to think that history
moves in a line from naive art to
sophisticated art from short
disease-ridden human lives to long and
healthy ones from poverty to abundance
from ignorance to knowledge the idea
that history means progress is very new
like almost all of the 250,000 year
history of humans looks more like a sine
curve than an ascending line and
whatever progress we've made toward
justice or equality or shared prosperity
is fragile because it's new it's easy to
forget that because the new is all
around us from broadband internet to
Italian tomatoes to even the Pantheon
but all of that occurred in the last 1%
of human history which is maybe a
reminder that a lot of what we think of
as inevitable or natural about
humaneness really isn't inequality of
wealth isn't natural nor is
anthropogenic climate change or
political polarization on the other hand
literacy also is a natural nor is
freedom of speech nor is it natural for
Rome to be three hours from Florence
these conditions result from choices
we've made collectively every day we're
choosing what to value what to worship
what to paint and through the haze of
history the humans of the future will
know us by the choices that we are
making together right now Hank I'll see
you on Friday